celebrating a festival of colors all for
a good cause
a special event is underway right now
it's right near
at the vegas roots community garden
right near bonanza and mlk
madison kimbrough joins us live from
that event with the latest details
madison sasha it is a lot of fun here
you can see the music and the colors
behind me
as people are all decked out in their
wear with all the colors and everything
and such
a lot of people came out the event
started at three o'clock and there are
arts and crafts there's music as you can
hear
and tons of vendors now take a look at
the shots that we took earlier
for those unfamiliar of what holy is
it's a popular ancient
hindu festival also known as the
festival of love and the festival of
colors
celebrating growth as we approach a new
season now it's typically celebrated by
applying
colored powder on each other to enjoy
the colors of life as you can see people
are doing out here
and that's exactly what people did the
festival is taking place here at the
vegas
roots community garden which is a local
non-profit that teaches health
and wellness to the community community
garden leader tamika henry says
the meaning behind this festival fits
perfectly with the vegas roots message
end of march actually marked our 11th
year anniversary
and is the holy festival is just a
representation a celebration of spring
you know and that transition from winter
to spring and what better place
to have a festival like this than here
at the garden so
the holy festival of colors and vegas
roots it was a perfect connection
now tickets are just ten dollars and
available on site when you arrive
admission is free for those 10 and
younger and you know what just check
out it is so fun here the event lasts
till 7 pm today
there is a lot going on so come on down
now covet guidelines are in place so
make sure you
mask up i'll tell you what i am such a
target here
because i don't have a white shirt on so
people are really just wanting to throw
things at me
so i i better get behind the camera
sending it back to you sasha